[Music]
hello
what's your favorite scary movie
ghostface is back and scary as ever
now's the time to make a new screen
because we have a special story to tell
that connects the legacy cast members
with the new cast into the world of
woodsboro
my character of sam becomes the target
of the ghostface killer who is this
someone who knows your little secret
she seeks dewey for help
dewey he's pulled back in because he's
still got a huge heart and really wants
to help sydney she's moved on in her
life it's happening
three attacks so far
and then chaos ensues
it's just the perfect mix of new energy
and also keeping in what made it so
special in the first place i don't think
it's exactly what people are expecting
there's things that happen in this that
are kind of shocking i still can't
believe it
i've been through this a lot whoever
this is is gonna keep coming for you so
so i want you to help us kill him
so many twists and turns who's the
killer who's not we don't know
[Music]
sounds about right
[Applause]
[Music]
this isn't funny amber when do you like
to play a game tara
[Laughter]
all doors locked
doors unlocked
hello
it's happening
three attacks so far do you have a gun
i'm sydney prescott of course i have a
gun
something about this one just feels
different
samantha
i'm i know who you are
i've been through this
a lot
this is your life now which means that
whoever this is is going to keep coming
for you
you ready
for this
there's certain rules
to surviving
the attacks were all on people related
to the original killers
whatever his link is to our past
it's pulled us all back here
and i won't sleep until he's in the
ground
hello
it's an honor
[Music]
you